y bueno hola bueno hay que continuar con
los triángulos 30 60 90 así que voy a
borrar todo esto y bueno solo como
repaso de lo que hemos aprendido o
espero que hayamos aprendido el mínimo
lo que acabamos de ver es que si tenemos
un triángulo 30 60 90 y bueno una vez
más recuerda que esto solamente aplica
triángulos 30 60 90 aquí está el ángulo
de 30 grados aquí está el ángulo de 60
grados y este otro son de 90 aquí si yo
te digo que la hipotenusa tiene longitud
h y bueno aprendimos que el lado opuesto
al ángulo de 30 grados este lado el más
corto del triángulo es h sobre 2 y
también aprendimos que el otro lado un
poco más largo en el lado opuesto al
ángulo de 60 grados es raíz de 3 sobre 2
por la hipotenusa así que bueno ya con
esto hagamos un problema donde usamos
esta información digamos que yo tengo un
triángulo este es un triángulo
rectángulo y digamos que este ángulo
mide 30 y si este ángulo mide 30
entonces bueno este 90 y este debe medir
entonces 60 grados este mide
y digamos que la hipotenusa mide 12 la
hipotenusa la longitud de la hipotenusa
es de 12 sabemos que la hipotenusa
porque es el lado opuesto al ángulo de
90 ahora cuánto mide este lado cuánto
mide bueno pues este es el lado opuesto
al ángulo de 30 grados o al de 90 grados
es opuesto al de 30 cierto así que bueno
este triángulo lo dibujé un poco
diferente y el ángulo de 30 grados se
abre hacia este lado también es el lado
más corto y aprendimos que el lado
opuesto al ángulo de 30 grados tiene
longitud de la mitad de la hipotenusa
así que la hipotenusa mide 12 por lo
tanto este lado entonces cuánto mide
bueno mide 6 y este lado que es el
opuesto al ángulo de 60 grados es igual
a raíz de 3 sobre 2 por la hipotenusa
así que entonces es raíz de 3 sobre 2
por 12 lo cual es igual a 6 raíz de 3
algo que también es interesante es que
el lado más corto que no es la
hipotenusa mide raíz de 3 más largo que
el lado más corto bueno si no te quiero
confundir pero bueno hagamos otro
ejemplo digamos que
y aquí tenemos otro triángulo y entonces
aquí este ángulo es de 30 y es un ángulo
es un triángulo rectángulo así que si yo
te digo que bueno que este lado tiene
longitud de 55 entonces cuál es la
medida de este otro lado cuánto cuánto
mide este lado ahora primero que todo
veamos cuánto información tenemos el 5 a
qué a qué ángulo corresponde el lado el
lado que mide 5 sabemos que este ángulo
mide 60 porque el otro mide 30 y otro 90
entonces 5 este lado opuesto al ángulo
de 60 grados si x es la hipotenusa
porque x es el lado opuesto al ángulo de
90 grados y también x lion y la
hipotenusa es el lado más largo del
triángulo rectángulo y sabemos por
nuestra fórmula que 5 es igual a raíz de
3 sobre 2 por la hipotenusa la cual es
en este ejemplo x y ahora bueno
resolvemos para x multiplicamos ambos
lados delante de la ecuación por el
inverso de raíz de 3 sobre 2 así que dos
sobre raíz de 3 de este lado y también 2
sobre
de 3 también de este lado ahora aquí
aquí no te quiero confundir así que
tacho esto así que bueno obtenemos 10
sobre la raíz de 3 y este 12 cancela con
este 2 este raíz de 3 se cancela con
esta raíz de 3 es igual a equis ahora
bien si tú has mirado las últimas
presentaciones que he hecho bueno te
diste cuenta que esto pudo ser la
respuesta correcta sin embargo tenemos
un raíz de 3 en el denominador así que
el cual el cual no agrada mucho a las
personas porque es un número irracional
en el denominador y podríamos debatir en
por qué esto es incorrecto o malo o lo
que sea pero no lo vamos a hacer así que
bueno racionalicemos este denominador x
es igual a 10 sobre raíz de 3 y para
racionalizar el denominador podemos
multiplicar el numerador y denominador
por raíz de tres así que raíz de tres
sobre raíz de tres eso es cómo
multiplicar por uno no lo deje igual así
que esto es igual a 10 raíz de tres
sobre raíz de 3 por raíz de 3 es
simplemente 3 por lo tanto la hipotenusa
tiene longitud de 10 raíz de 3 sobre 3
mide la hipotenusa y bueno tal vez ojalá
no te haya confundido ahora esto es raíz
de 3 sobre 3 es la hipotenusa sabemos
que el lado opuesto al ángulo de 30
grados mide la mitad de eso así que es 5
raíz de 3 sobre 3 y bueno en fin yo creo
que ahora ya puedes darte una idea de lo
que ya te diste una idea de lo que es un
triángulo 30 60 90 y ya estás listo para
hacer algunos ejercicios en un nivel más
elevado sobre el teorema de pitágoras
así que bueno diviértete nos vemos